[Music]
the beast that comes out of the earth
tell the inhabitants of the earth to
make an image to the beast
gives life to it
causes people to worship it see
revelation chapter 13 verses 14 and 15.
what is the image and its significance
the imp now the word image is important
an image precise reflection of an
original keep this in mind we were made
in the image of god we must reflect god
christ object lessons 53
69 paragraph 1 when the character of
christ shall be perfectly reproduced in
his people then we'll come to claim them
as a dawn jesus said in john 14
9 he that have seen me have seen the
father so jesus was the image of the
father we are to be the image of christ
we were made through adam in the image
of god now we were to look like god
behave like god think like god
philippians 2 verse 5 let this mind be
in you which was also in christ jesus
hebrews 12 10 we are to partake of the
holiness of god ii peter chapter one
verse four we must partake of the divine
nature of god we can never be god but we
must be godly and god like we must
reflect the image of god now
the mark the image of the beast is a
system just like the beast
and the horrible thing about this system
is is a religious system
controlling the state to enforce its
will on the population let me say it
again a religious system controlling
secular leaders to impose its will upon
the general population that very system
will be established it will be called it
will be called the image to the beast
and its creation will be fueled by
efforts from the beast of revelation 13
11 to 88
which is the united states bluntly put
the united states will lead the way in
setting up a system that is similar to
the papal system and the united states
being the most influential country on
earth we lead the world in adopting and
following this system which is apparent
and simply idolatry and so the image of
the beast is a system just like the
beast
no variation just like the beast it will
be initiated by this country known for
religious freedom
thank you very much
let me say in revelation 30
and he had power to give life to the
image of the beast
now
the the energy behind that beast will be
this this uh
the energy behind the image of the beast
will be the beast of revelation 13 11
through 18 as verily as the energy
behind the man of sin is the energy of
satan but since the beast of revelation
13 11 to 18 exercises the same power as
the beast of revelation 13 1-10 and that
power is the devil verse four then the
power that motivates the image of the
beast is the same power that motivates
the beast which is satanic power
and forces interesting
that as many as would not worship the
image of the beast should be killed
there will be a death penalty for those
who do not worship that system as verily
as there was a death penalty in the days
of daniel for those who did not bow to
the beast that nebuchadnezzar set up
sorry my brother interrupting you go
ahead
now that's okay um it's just interesting
that america um with its constitution
and all of its laws and so on protect
human rights and liberative conscience
that we would come to in history where
we're going to force the conscience to
to worship a certain that is against
god's law and the country was built on
nations in god's word so it's just
amazing that's why it's called a
lamb-like beast
yes that's right
wolves in sheep's clothing
you